oh
o o
[Musique]
là
alain carignon vous aimez le pouvoir
c'est votre vie j'aime l'action l'action
je suis pas dans leur lettre
je suis pas dans le lavoir je suis dans
le faire parce que c'est quand même
incroyable
vous avez beaucoup problèmes judiciaires
2020 37 ans après votre première
élection à la mairie de grenoble en 1983
où vous gagnez au premier tour à la
surprise générale
là vous remettez le couvert avec elle en
échec surprise générale oui mais quand
même vous remettez le couvert 37 ans
après en vous disant je veux ma mairie
de grenoble
j'ai pas altruiste le être utile aux
autres à mes concitoyens etc
c'est une satisfaction parce que j'aime
pas le vide qui études j'aime pas
l'immobilité intellectuelle j'aime pas
qu'on ne veuille pas bougé oui
puis vous dites 37 ans après mais je
compte pas les années il ya quelque
chose d'apollonia me savais au fond si
on réfléchit après parce que le fait de
fond c'est ça fait bouger l'image ça
fait bouger les lignes
il n'y a pas d'issue mais quand on bouge
l'issue se se découvre vous avez un
petit côté bonapartiste la ba écoute et
il y avait un routage est mon ami de
lucas l'a77 anges quand je lui demandais
de faire quelque chose qu'ils ne
connaissaient pas il dit et je vous
réponds oui je réfléchis après c'est un
peu votre cas oui parce que si c'est
comme ça qu'on est positif c'est qu'on
trouve des solutions
quand je voyais mes concitoyens comme mr
1 grenoble qui venait d'apporter des
solutions inextricable pour lui mais
c'était très important de voir le maire
je dirais d'abord oui parce que le fait
qu'on fasse le chemin ensemble pour sa
sortie ce à l'aide aussi et quand vous
avez exercé le pouvoir vous
réfléchissiez après donc quand même non
mais c'est l'idée quand même c'était
l'engagement on le regarde on y va et
l'engagement qui compte parce que c'est
ça qui fait qui fait bouger parce qu'on
a trop d'immobilisme politique on a trop
de non décision on a trop de non action
et donc on a trop peu de résultats moi
que vous dites 83 je suis mère j'ai 33
ou 34 ans c'est formidable je réfléchis
pas une minute mendès-france m'avait dit
dix ou quinze ans avant dans un déjeuner
renoncer au gaullisme quoi c'est fini
d'accord
et c'est pour ça peut-être aussi que
vous avez cette gnac et vous avez ce cet
appétit de faire de faire bouger les
lignes c'est que vous n'êtes pas issus
des grandes écoles
aujourd'hui les ceux qui s'engagent en
politique c'est souvent en sciences po
l'ena à normale sup vous non c'est pas
du tout votre parcours dont je prends
mon parcours j'ai un parcours les gars
de terrain j'ai un parcours
universitaire mais c'est pas mon
parcours c'est l'un je suis gaulliste
dalstein je suis dans une banlieue
communiste le communisme municipal ce
sens qu'il ya derrière totalitarisme que
je rejette et d'instinct je suis hostile
à cela d'instinct je suis gaulliste ma
génération et anti gaulliste au pour ma
génération de gaulle ces francos c'est
les crs ss je suis donc ultra
minoritaire mais ça ne change rien et
alors vous avez une ascension absolument
au fulgurante
vous avez été ministre deux fois
ministre mais quand on est ministre là
ça change un peu la dimension que vous
êtes obligés de prendre des risques
aussi non toujours sur l'écologie il y
avait la conscience et que l'on vous a
été ministre les collections et de la
communication la communication quelques
années après j'ai fait la cinquième
chaîne de télévision j'ai fait les
quotas de chanson française
voyez j'ai fait l'exception culturelle
et à chaque fois ou prenez des risques
oui ces risques là ils sont calculés
puisque vous dites moi je fais je pars
et puis après je je corrige
disons que par exemple dans un dans une
affaire aussi international que le gâte
les négociations comme les etats-unis
mettent tous les moyens y compris en
dessous de la ceinture
pour gagner il faut se battre c'est dur
le pouvoir
d'ailleurs vous avez un sacré caractère
parce que quand on vous dit ministre de
l'écologie on vous propose d'avoir un
secrétariat d'état public non masta moi
je suis pas secrétaire d'état puis
ministre et à cette occasion
et bien vous allez vivre un événement
qui va marquer l'histoire du 20e siècle
je vous invite à regarder ceux ci
professeur l'opinion publique en france
s'étonne du manque d'informations
chiffrées sur la radioactivité en italie
et en rfa qu'en pensez vous
je n'ai pas personnellement
d'informations chiffrées sur la
radioactivité en italie et en france
nous savons par contre ce qu'il y a
comme radioactivité dans notre pays
est ce que je peux vous dire maintenant
après les chiffres que nous avons
vérifié longuement par de très
nombreuses mesures des centaines qui ont
d'ailleurs été publié et distribué à la
sp hier c'est que la radioactivité
retomber sur notre pays au cours de
toutes ces affaires se situe entre la
moitié et le tiers de ce qui est tombée
sur les autres pays européens
l'angleterre et l'espagne sera pas
vraiment une situation on est au mois de
mai 1986 vous êtes ministre de
l'écologie il ya cet accident nucléaire
de tchernobyl en union soviétique
actuellement en ukraine et le professeur
pellerin dit menon la france n'a pas
d'effet substantielle de cet accident
et vous vous êtes ministre vous êtes
obligé de vous exprimer à la télévision
et vous dites vous reprenez ce que vous
savez est ce que le professeur pellerin
notamment vous dit et vous reconnaissez
quand même que des années après que
finalement vous dit pas la vérité je dis
la vérité que les fonctionnaires le
professionnel rock est un homme intègre
et relève avec les capteurs qui nous
indique un ministre va pas se substituer
aux capteurs je n'ai pas compétence sur
le nucléaire et alain madelin de mise
lundi l'industrie et par contre je vois
le dysfonctionnement matière
d'information et donc un an après que
fait voter une loi à l'unanimité du
parlement une loi sur l'information en
cas de risque majeur qui modifiait la
donne pour l'avenir ça a détruit sa
carrière ou sa réputation il a été
poursuivie jusqu'à la fin de sa vie et
il a gagné tous les procès car lui a
toujours donné sa vérité scientifique
en fonction des éléments dont il
disposait ça nuit à votre carrière à
votre réputation sa maman non parce que
moi je n'avais pas la compétence avait
été programmé par la presse à l'époque
où j'avais pas n'avait pas la compétence
du nucléaire c'était alain madelin
donc moi je juge est juste tirer les
conséquences du dysfonctionnement en
matière d'information
c'est toujours cette volonté d'agir
quand il ya quelque chose qui n'a pas
fonctionné il faut corriger deux fois
ministre
une fois avec chirac première
cohabitation deuxième cohabitation avec
balladur vous avez été l'otage de la
guerre balladur
chirac non parce qu'il faut choisir et
donc au moment dans le roman où j'ai
choisi edouard balladur on est l'otage
de personne ont fait son choix
c'est la violence du pouvoir ça la
guerre entre ces deux hommes oui il faut
se remettre dans le contexte de l'usure
apparente de jacques chirac qui a prouvé
qui a prouvé le contraire ensuite de la
capacité de l'homme d'état d'edouard
balladur qui était incontestable quand
il a pris le pouvoir en 93 il a rétabli
l'autorité de l'état et pour les
gaullistes l'autorité de l'état c'est un
élément capital qui permet d'agir là
aussi en 95 vous étiez pour qui à
l'élection présidentielle d'edouard
balladur dont vous avez lâché chirac à
ce moment là oui dont vous étiez un des
poulains quand même j'avais oui enfin je
j'avais aussi conquis par moi même j'ai
été totalement indépendant et autonome
ne nous attendait mais j'ai toujours été
des liens particuliers avec jacques
chirac que j'ai conservée je pense
jusqu'au bout mais en 95 il a fallu
faire un choix que j'avais fait comme
ministres doivent allier pourquoi parce
que si en 93 quand jacques chirac s'est
lancé dans l'élection présidentielle je
devais être derrière lui fallait que je
démissionne du gouvernement et
kilomètres derrière malheureusement vous
n'avez pas pu faire la faire cette
campagne de 95 1994 vous êtes à grenoble
vous avez un déjeuner pour ce un coup de
fil ou de suite de votre femme qui vous
dit un juge va vous appeler c'est le
début alors ils étaient voilées que des
emmerdes et le bien sûr la vie tombées
la gêne et férocité de la vie vous voyez
plus rien que ça bien sûr c'est normal
après on était
c'est pas les férocité de la vie c'est
la férocité de la politique aussi de la
vie vous savez la vie est féroce pour
tout le monde il faut bien classés
férocité et drame c'est pas le drame
c'est pas un drame non parce que le
drame c'est la perte de notre cher
d'accord la férocité de la vie c'est une
épreuve qu'il faut essayer de surmonter
à ce moment là je raisonne pas du tout
comme elle et résonne à l'instant bien
sûr je suis sur le le coup et le mauvais
cours ou s'effondrent d'abord mais on
veut pas trop s'attarder sur ces
effondrements personnel est le premier
que vous prévenez c'est celui qui
restera toujours votre ami nicolas
s'apprécie vous l'appelez immédiatement
quasiment que le disant je vais avoir
des problèmes judiciaires et vous
démissionnez vous prévenez edouard
balladur et vous démissionnez hélas
après c'est un calvaire
vous connaissez l'humiliation vous étiez
préparé à ça donc si vous étiez dit que
la politique c'était ça aussi
non c'est pas c'est la vie vous savez il
faut pas sacraliser l'homme public
sauf que quand on est un homme de
pouvoir oui vous savez davantage que rim
et les épreuves de la vie beaucoup de
personnes n'ont pas non très important
des épreuves des férocité des pertes
d'emplois qui des familles qui se
disloque etc
tout ceci c'est la vie vous savez moi je
pour moi le bonheur de la vie c'est pas
la quiétude de la vie le bonheur de la
vie c'est aussi d'affronter c'est tous
ces éléments c'est au fond aussi une
forme de satisfaction ne soit que tous
ces éléments qui s'acharnent outils qui
sont contre vous ne voulez pas c'est
vous êtes qualifiés d'une certaine
manière pour pour traverser ces épreuves
alors vous que dc l'humiliation vous
connaissez et horde de journalistes les
transferts entre la prison
et le palais de justice les rendez-vous
avec le juge d'instruction
vous êtes l'homme sous la vème
république qui a fait plus de prison oui
29 mois et vous l'avez raconté dans un
livre qui est magnifique qui s'appelle
une saison dans la nuit terrible 7 cet
univers carcéral
oui bien sûr bien sûr vous invite en
plus une médiation est allé jusqu'au
bout
regardez la prison saint joseph est un
ensemble de cinq bâtiments au centre de
lyon près de la gare de perrache
klaus barbie qui occupe une cellule de
10 mètres carrés équipée d'un sanitaire
est totalement isolé les dix neuf autres
détenus de ce bâtiment ont été
transférés et 24 gardiens assurent la
surveillance et la sécurité du criminel
de guerre
cette cellule de klaus barbie criminels
de guerre vous allez l'occuper qu'est-ce
que vous êtes 10 vous saviez que c'était
là c'est les deux parties non je n'ai su
qu'après mais c'est sûr que le gardien
qui a fait un témoignage très hostile à
ma personne
après après mon départ on ne s'ennuyait
pas du tout sympathique parce
qu'évidemment il venait me voir en
disant alors faire comme avec monsieur
barbier on va discuter et c'est harry
donc je n'avais pas du tout envie oui et
donc qu'il a gardé un très mauvais
souvenir de moi cela étant c'est le
hasard de la vie
c'est ainsi vous avez le temps on aurait
pu vous mettre dans une autre cellule
kamel chenni 6 cellules d'isolement de
l'actualité c'est des cellules et tissus
et cellules d'isolement
oui c'est nécessaire qu'on isole les
personnes en prison
vous n'avez eu aucun régime
particulier un hippie entre la france et
un régime égalitaire oui c'est sa
qualité
les allemands des rites vous demandiez
rien et ça ne vous n'avez pas le droit
de demander mais c'est sa force la force
et que tout le monde est traité de la
même façon
c'est quelque chose qui est
consubstantiel autres pays ce régime
légalité et vous vous êtes la
manifestation que ça en fait vous avez
rien demandé vous êtes devenu maire de
grenoble en 1983 personnes nous
attendaient
on vous propose un poste de au
gouvernement dit non non moi je veux un
poste supérieur donc c'est vraiment la
force du poignet vous vous allez
courageux non je sais pas j'ai pas de
courage après tout vu une forme
d'inconscience
c'est à dire se dire que moi je suis
pour l'action je me suis pour résoudre
les problèmes et coop
on me pose est donc si je sais que par
exemple on me dit que vous exploitez
environnement c'est pas possible parce
que c'était déjà important
d'environnement ça sera pas c'est
sarkozy qui en fera le ministère d'état
mais c'est déjà important
donc je ne pourrais pas agir à partir de
là ça ne m'intéresse pas si je peux être
utile si je peux faire c'est pas
altruiste
je ne me définis pas comme altruiste ça
me donne satisfaction que d'être utile
qu'est ce que vous allez faire en prison
j'ai lu j'ai écrit voilà ouais je fais
du sport
vous avez pensé
au suicide bien sûr dans votre livre une
saison dans la nuit vous dites j'ai
pensé à quelqu'un qui pour qui j'ai
finalement beaucoup de respect beaucoup
d'admiration pierre bérégovoy on
s'attend pas à ça parce que il a eu des
problèmes qui l'ont conduit au suicide
mais il n'est pas de votre bord
politique vous l'avez peut-être même
affrontés dans des débats pourquoi vous
pensiez un pierre bérégovoy oui
maintenant voici le destin des hommes
qui sont acculés qui ont la meute et il
ya un livre excellent la meute
ouais c'est yann moix mais c'est la
meute et dans ce cas là c'est là où je
reviens à l'idée à deux idées des idées
frein qu' il n'y a pas d'impasse pour
celui qui bouge et il ya une autre
inégalité c'est l'énergie
vous avez une force intérieure terrible
non l'inégalité de l'énergie en avoir ou
pas n'est pas lié au raisonnement ou à
l'intelligence si vous avez l'énergie
c'est génétique et vous n'y pouvez rien
donc vous n'avez pas du tout à vous en
glorifier et vous vous avez l'énergie
l'énergie
vous êtes un père dont vous parliez des
médias la meute votre perte et
journalistes oui quand même journal que
bon le mien salle où j'ai commencé que
vos débuts fils libéré lui il est resté
lui toute sa vie et il vous a donné
cette énergie l'énergie vient de ma mère
mon père était
donc ce n'est pas n'est pas une énergie
exceptionnelle entre l actif d'accord et
donc et vous avez aussi fréquenté dans
cet univers carcéral a disons non à des
voyous des gens qui étaient là parce
qu'ils avaient trafiqué la drogue et où
vous aviez des conversations avec eux
mais là aussi vous avez partout on est
on essaye d'être et qu'il apprend on
fait les courriers ont été utiles à quoi
vous sert il et les choses se dire à
donner des conseils vous gériez leur
affaire aussi non non non pas qu'il
n'ait pas vous voir en disant voilà
qu'est ce que je dois faire
non moi j'essayais de les orienter pour
pour sortir de la situation dans
laquelle ils étaient et dans laquelle
ils voulaient perdurait ce qui était une
impasse pour eux et pour leur avenir
la redevance est à venir cette
délinquance dans laquelle il était elle
n'avait aucun avenir ni pour eux ni pour
leurs familles et vous vous étiez parler
encore oui j'étais de quelqu'un qui a
été condamné pour des financements
politiques sans aucun enrichissement
personnel
à une période où les financements
politiques étaient monnaie courante
puisqu'il n'y avait pas de loi
j'ai payé ma dette à ajuste donc j'ai
payé ma dette à la société
je n'ai pas juste ou injuste j'ai payé
ma dette à la société je suis libre à
l'égard de la société
s'il ya un homme public qui peut parler
de l'avenir et des idées librement parce
que mais vous ne vous êtes pas enrichi
personnellement où il n'y a pas eu de
vous étiez au courant de ce qui se
faisait autour de vous parce qu'en fait
tout est parti d'une histoire d'un
journal que vous aviez créé qui
s'appelait dauphiné news et qui a eu des
problèmes financiers qui ont été
renflouées par une société qui était
très connu à l'époque service des eaux
avec un homme d'ailleurs qui jouera un
rôle alors le rpr qui s'appelle jérôme
monod vous étiez au courant de tout ce
renflouage d'argent le financement
politique était naturel
je veux dire tout mon tous les hommes
politiques fonctionner cette façon a
pourri la vie finalement de la balle non
pas les politiques de très peu d'hommes
bourg d'histoire potable soit pourri la
vie de très peu d'hommes politiques pas
part à la pratique
enfin général mais j'avais c'est qu'on
n'est pas il ya des excès de vitesse et
en a dix qui sont pas pris en excès de
vitesse et vous vous êtes vous êtes
verbaliser c'est pas parce que les
autres ne l'ont pas été que vous n'avez
pas fait d'excès de vitesse
il ya une formule tac à utiliser bernard
henri lévy qui pour résumer ça c'est
vous avez fait un pas de trop dans
l'époque suivante avec les sabots de la
précédente
c'est exactement notre cas aujourd'hui
ça serait plus possible de aujourd'hui
la loi la loi il n'y avait pas de loi et
c'est mieux qu'il voit bien sûr alors il
ya un homme qui va être votre
interlocuteur pendant toute cette
période
c'est le juge courroye juge
d'instruction et votre expérience vous a
conduit à réfléchir et vous dites vous
dites il faut supprimer cette fonction
de juge d'instruction parce que
finalement juge d'instruction ça de
travail qu à charge et à décharge
oui dans lequel juge courroye s'était il
avait une ambition personnelle de
promotion et donc il fallait qu'il se
plus payer de personnes célèbres
puisqu'il était promu il a voulu se
promouvoir sur votre dos alors oui elle
est d'ailleurs il a réussi ce jusqu'au
moment où il a échoué parce que j'ai
abandonné on a eu des problèmes parce
que quand vous êtes dans le faux ça
finit toujours par apparaître
ah oui il était dans le faux bien sûr
pour lui-même et c'est un homme qui
était mue par l'ambition une ambition et
sans écouter c'est pas non plus les
ambitions sont pas totalement anormal
simplement quand elle broie des vies
elles peuvent être tout à fait
discutable c'est frais c'est son cas
mais peu importe puisque à la fin c'est
ce termine mal pour lui pas aussi mal
que qui le que ce pourrait être autorisé
ce que je sais ah oui vous savez quoi
sur la façon dont il a servi les
pouvoirs d'accord y compris celui de
nicolas sarkozy
c'est pour ça que je dis c'est qu'on
dise que je sais cela étant je crois que
cette fonction est une fonction très
difficile parce que c'est très difficile
d'être neutre dans un dossier de ce type
parce qu'on fait alors que donc il faut
vraiment modifier les choses
moi je suis pour que des procureurs qui
est qu'ils soient probables aux élus
désormais qu'ils puissent eux
instruire répondre donc il faut couper
le cordon lui dit call c'est intéressant
ce que vous dites entre le ministre de
la justice et le parquet non je ne suis
pas pour que le pouvoir politique n'est
plus de pouvoir ah d'accord moi je suis
pour que le pouvoir politique dispose de
pouvoirs les concerts dans la politique
pénale dans toutes les politiques parce
que plus on déshabille le pouvoir
politique - celui ci peut avoir des
résultats
on a une situation schizophrénique de la
part des français ils veulent que les
hommes politiques est de moins en moins
de pouvoir ils veulent utiliser des
résultats ouais c'est contradictoire on
ne peut pas avoir des résultats
si on n'a pas tous les pouvoirs si on
n'a pas donné pouvoir le pouvoir mais
pour ce qui est de la justice justement
parce que c'est intéressant vous dites
je suis pour un procureur élu mais s'il
est élu le procureur il doit en référer
quand même à son ministre la joie il en
référera au peuple c'est lui qui
l'aurait élu parce qu'on ne peut plus si
vous voulez exercer aujourd'hui il faut
que d'aider les procureurs soient les
mandataires du peuple exerce en fonction
du peuple il faut qu'il le fasse justice
à l'américaine alors il ya pour partie
pour partie on a vu ce que ça donnait
avec l' affaire dsk
vous êtes livrés en pâture aussi oui oui
mais on est livré en pâture de toute
façon puisqu'il n'y a plus de secret de
l'instruction
y a plus que ce serait une solution saas
est aussi une chose avoir le rôle des
médias vous parlez de votre père keith
et journalistes et les médias
aujourd'hui sont à votre avis contre le
pouvoir nécessairement donc c'est une
forme de contre pouvoir mettre dans les
dossiers judiciaires ils sont
instrumentalisés par leurs sources c'est
évident leur donne des informations au
compte-gouttes en fonction de ce
qu'elles veulent faire passer mais on ne
peut pas en vouloir aux médias que de
reproduire les informations dont il
dispose vous vous êtes toujours méfié
les journalistes mais fier non non non
monsieur je suis pas méfiant d'accord je
fais bottes plutôt confiance a priori
alors vous dit en fait finalement ce qui
est intéressant c'est pas de chuter
cette se relever vous l'avez dit ça oui
vous avez des gens qui vous ont aidé
pour ça oui mais j'ai bien sûr beaucoup
d'amis vous avez été entouré vous n'avez
pas on vous a pas laissé de non non
jamais jamais et il ya un homme qui
apparaît dans le paysage on s'attend pas
le voir là
bernard henri lévy pourquoi il vient
vers vous c'est lui qui vient vers vous
oui parce que d'abord on se connait si
on échange beaucoup avec lui et jo j'ai
beaucoup avec lui avec plusieurs
intellectuels français plusieurs
écrivains étaient en prison ah non avant
depuis les années 80 d'accord je connais
alors vous n'avez vous n'êtes pas d'un
milieu intellectuel et tout ça enfin
vous mais je suis passionné de
littérature de b depuis ma tendre
enfance vous échanger avec lui jean
vigne oralement cause pour vous oui il
prend fait et cause mais pas comme des
rats aussi beaucoup d'écrivains me
soutiennent ford lance un appel françois
de sales ans qui écrit en figaro un
papier pour s'étonner de la situation
que l'on fait j'ai beaucoup de deux
personnes de ce genre de écrivains
philosophes mais aussi line renaud qui
est très activement se mobilise beaucoup
d'hommes et de femmes de luc ferry qui
très différents et quand vous sortez de
prison vous allez le juge hervé renard
aurait évité pourquoi donc ce qui me dit
il veut me protéger il veut me
réconforter qui me protège et peut-être
contre moi même dit qu'on de votre
encontre l'une l'univers que je vais
redécouvrir et donc ma femme et moi ils
nous demandent de venir chez lui et de
et de nos ressources et et vos
ressources par les nourritures
spirituelles par par toutes les
autorités
mais surtout et le temps que le temps
dont nous avons besoin
vous êtes vous resté combien temps celui
au genre quinze jours trois semaines et
de ce moment là vous avez toujours gardé
je dirais votre univers intellectuel
oui
vous parliez de yann moix tout à l'heure
ça fait partie de nuit qu'il fréquentait
beaucoup qui intervient après lui bien
après et vous demandent conseil ces gens
là aussi kim prend n'ont pas besoin de
conseils non mais qui prend ma défense
bien après il ya deux mois que très
courageusement vous êtes un homme
étonnant parce que un homme de l'action
mais qui adorez la réflexion finalement
oui bien sûr qu'en jeu quand je
plaisante sûr on agit on réfléchit après
ça n'empêche pas de réfléchir mais ce
que je veux dire c'est qu'il ya deux
hommes il ya l'homme d'action qui
l'homme public celui qui doit réaliser
celui qui doit concrétiser et celui qui
doit être très en répondre agir et
depuis il ya une part de lui-même qui
est effectivement dans les change d'idée
d'intellectuels avec des hommes de
littérature ça c'est pour moi c'est
essentiel à ma nature
le pouvoir il est moral c'est pour moi
la mort à l'aller personnel tout ce qui
est moral collectif c'est l'ordre moral
et tous ceux qui font état de la morale
en permanence sont en général des
tartuffes parce que j'ai constaté dans
tout ce qui monte écrivait l'onglet de
matthieu ricard quand j'étais en privé
avec lequel j'avais aussi des liens lui
dalaï lama depuis très longtemps depuis
les années 80 et allemandes et est donc
toutes ces personnes qui ont une valeur
morale ne la met jamais en avant parce
qu'ils savent qu'ils ne sont jamais à la
hauteur de la morale à laquelle ils
aspirent
et tous ceux qui ont très peu de morale
et qui sont des artus ne parle que
d'elle vous méfier des donneurs de
leçons rage non surtout que dg
l'expérience de cela
ceux qui en donnent le plus sont ceux
qui méritent le moins d'en donner alors
bhl matthieu ricard
le dalaï lama et puis une femme toujours
à vos côtés
ça peut plier
c'est jacqueline jacqueline qui du début
à la fin sera toujours là c'est elle qui
vous prévient d'ailleurs la première du
coup de fil que vous allez recevoir du
juge courroye et elle a été essentielle
vous partager tout tout vous secrets
avec elle et vous ne la mettez jamais en
avant et elle ne se met jamais en avant
dit elle qu'il se met l'avion devrait
mais vous accompagne ouais et déteste la
vie publique et l'affichage donc à la
une vie personnelle et qui était à
l'écart de tout ce qui est public mais
qui effectivement est elle vous a tenu
plus propre plus que proches de moi nous
sommes visionner fusionner dans ce sens
que oui on se parle tout le temps on
peut pas faire de la politique si on n'a
pas une compagne un compagnon c'est pas
possible je ne sais pas parce que je
peux pas répondre pour tout le monde ce
que je sais c'est que nous avons besoin
les uns des autres dans ces proximité
tout en étant nous-mêmes indépendant on
n'a pas les mêmes conceptions la même
façon de vivre et c'est cette
complémentarité qui fait que nous sommes
bien ensemble
et oui il faut toujours avoir un jardin
privé quand on est au public mais on
peut très bien avoir des conceptions de
vie très différente entre un homme et
une femme et être ensemble de façon très
forte en 2002 d'où songer à revenir en
politique
et vous voulez réintégrer le rpr à
l'époque où l'ump et eelv à quito belley
ars et bien sûr il y en a un qui vous
impose c'est finalement celui qui sera
toujours à vos côtés c'est nicolas
sarkozy il doit vous imposer dans votre
propre famille politique je me souviens
plus comment ça s'est passé parce que
c'est un point de parts dans des tailles
mais nicolas sarkozy c'est un homme
courageux faut bien comprendre que le
qu'en-dira-t-on
ce n'est pas son problème et donc il a
la capacité d'affronter la meute
d'affronter l'opinion publique s'il le
faut et il a cette capacité de
convalescence là que je l'admirent et
que je trouve que c'est quelqu'un
d'important parce qu'il ya très peu
d'hommes d'état courageux
la politique c'est votre vie vous êtes
conseiller municipal maintenant vous
avez certes perdu les élections
l'élection municipale de grenoble en
2020 mais vous êtes au conseil municipal
le leader de l'opposition
absolument à voir donc après tout ce que
vous allez parce que ministre vous avez
été maire vous avez été président du
conseil général c'est quand même le
vouloir ça mais vous savez je n'ai
jamais raisonné en carrière toujours en
engagement moi je n'ai jamais prétendu
vouloir être être maire de grenoble
président du département etc
je suis arrivé dans une dans un
département où il y avait du goût doux
mermaz mendès-france et où tout était
fermé
ce n'était pas mon père ma nation je le
répète me dis venez de notre côté parce
que tout est fermé
ce n'était pas mon problème d'être élu
mon problème c'est de porter une
conviction d'avoir un engagement de
porter sa part de vérité et cette part
de vérité où elle est partagée où elle
ne l'est pas mais on ne s'en retire pas
quand il y avait 25 mille étudiants à
grenoble en 1968 et que nous étions
moins de 10 et moins de dix jeunes
gaullistes et que j'allais dans les
amphis lire pourquoi jeter pour de
gaulle et je me faisais sortir des
amphis façon discutable
ça n'était pas mon problème vous avez
parlé avec moi pendant près d'une
demi-heure
j'ai senti de l'émotion vous êtes ému
oui parce que je reviens sur du passé
alors que gaulliste le regard vers
l'avenir cette phrase du général de
gaulle vieil homme recrue des preuves
sentant venir le froid éternelle est
jamais là de gaieté dans l'eau ou à la
lueur de l'espérance c'est les mémoires
d'espoir
c'est superbe alors puisque vous étiez
de gaulle jeux cités nelson mandela je
ne perds jamais soit je gagne soit
j'apprends c'est vous tout à fait merci
alain gagnon merci
[Musique]